all right
so who is here
gimli x
let's have okay let's have a drink is a
good idea so let's accept
a3
so let's go for bishop g4 and this uh
shitty plan with uh castling queenside
yeah which is
i think which is almost losing for uh
for blackbeard
it's hard to prove
at least in a practical game
so of course f6
as can you receive
who is the most challenging person in
blitz
for me
well normally some strong players
in classical chess are also good in
blitz
that's the most usual scenario
and
well
i can't say that i play so much blitz
especially lately
i
fortunately or unfortunately i don't
have enough time
but i mean of course yeah okay it's
hard to play like with mabel's hikaru
within calireza
so i guess
i guess i have like 30
something like 32 hundreds on uh call in
one of my accounts
but uh
well
uh it was never about like breaking some
records so
it's more about having fun
let's go knight 5 24 yo c6 and then d3
and then i go for a mate
oh very smart
so the
daily wisdom is that you shouldn't
wander the mating one
and then maybe you can help for for for
a win
c5 was a good move
so i remove the rook from
from e8 so it's not getting
attack talky but this guy is like so so
street
i like the spirit
he just crashes through
thank you pneumonia
we should be free
well should i just take on d6 or this is
unnecessary
let's go for d3i i like to create some
more
some more mess on the board
and the reason is
because why not
do you watch marvel movies
yes why not i kind of i kind of like
comics movies
and some of them i just are just cool
so it's not about some
deep
uh deep plot uh some interesting story
normally but it's
it's also like it's just this kind of
another type of culture
i don't know let's go i'm not sure what
to do here just go for king a7 or maybe
queen
okay let's let's try queen d4
okay this is a grid but grid is bad
because picture is hanking
i knew he's going for this trap
calculated calculated guys calculated
okay maybe now i do free
do you still play hearthstone no not
really
okay let's play for the mate here
so we don't take the queen
we are trying to be precise till the end
thank you